l'action visa mobile la vie des normands
trépanier n'est plus la même depuis
longtemps son épouse souffre d'alzheimer
4 8 jours on était offert quoi c'est sûr
c'est une personne qui marche dans ta
face tu peux pas frotter l'épaule a pas
mal à l'épaule t'as pas mal aux jambes
mais pas mal à rien allez c'est qui ça
répond plus les premiers symptômes de la
maladie se sont manifestés en 2005 d
oubli mais aussi des crises de colère
les crises qui se sont accentuées plus
récemment on est où j'ai appris que la
personne qui me tombait d'en face il m'a
fait la crise l'étape hommes et femmes
c'était une lutte et tonino
à catane d'inventer ça fait mal tu
réfléchis je suis accroché en face ça
fait mal normand trépanier n'est pas le
seul projet dans à subir de la violence
physique et psychologique
le problème ici présent qu'une
professeur de l'université laval s'est
penché sur la question
elle réalise une des premières études au
québec sur ce qu'elle appelle la
maltraitance envers les projets dans
évidemment la maladie fait en sorte que
parfois les gens ont des comportements
qui sont dans le propriétaire verbal au
plan physique mais au-delà de ça il ya
également des personnes qui sont
difficiles et des personnes qui ont
toujours été difficiles toute leur vie
et ce bien avant la maladie le un
québécois sur quatre est un projet dans
selon les quelques études disponibles
plus de 15% d'entre eux subir et de la
maltraitance
ce sont des gens qui acceptent de donner
leur temps parfois de donner leur vie
même parce qu'il ya des projets dans
qu'il décède avant l'aider et je trouve
que ça n'a pas de bon sens que les
prochains dans ne soit pas suffisamment
soutenue et mais des ressources existent
pour la chercheuse les services ont
toutefois peu connu et ne sont pas
toujours adaptés aux besoins des projets
dans pour monsieur trépanier lettres
qu'il reçoit du clsc et d'organismes
communautaires quelques fois par semaine
puis fait le plus grand bien et la
relation avec son épouse s'est améliorée
j'étais incapable même si ça vous coûte
votre santé à vous je pense pas avoir eu
de la santé sera il peut attaquer ici
marie laurence de l'aîné radio canada
québec